he's like uh I didn't do any grilled in
this show man I tell you what let's do
the rest of the promo that way do it so
he said man I ain't doing it who you
Chris Evans well spider 2 y banana there
man so he's I didn't think about it
though like it I don't care in the end
but it's like just one of those things
like I said I'll do the show and then I
see Brian Carlin Frank Caliendo and then
they got some all had a break that's
just like that's not fair
but I'd okay it doesn't matter me you're
a hero a legend I'll tell you what man
you know who you are the comedic elite
Camille Leo Mac I would not have traded
Matt it was Camille as the that was the
wife fun Cosby Show man Camille it's
incredible it's a hard knocks man I love
that mother I'm going do you know do you
know him pretty well
Gruden yeah yeah he'll text me I'm such
a fan of his we know I love to see such
a fan you'll start doing this weekend
she'll start doing this would be like
you'll just start seeing good they doing
man
he texted me once at 3 in the morning
which i think is his lunch time he's
like I just got done doing a commercial
where I did an impersonation of you like
I didn't I was too scared to ask which
one it was I think it's the one where
he's talking to the tire it's like you
gotta get in there man yeah Todd you
have tank I tell ya so when I met him I
was Super Bowl in New Orleans and at Fox
they didn't care if I did impressions of
somebody they like just go surprise him
I did like a.j glaziers and FL I'm sorry
it's unbelievable how great this is and
then becomes Bobby Slayton I'm know if
it's right but it's you could do anybody
over at Fox ESPN they would always check
like we're gonna do shefter we'll see if
it's ok with shefter and they couldn't
call of course you can just do me
anytime you want have no problem with it
doesn't think it sounds like me would
let him do it so they check they checked
with Gruden and they wanted me to meet
him so this is him 810 years ago now I
got up there he's just holding the
coffee just making that Gruden face he's
right there
I go up to me just doing it back he's
like so you're the guy who does me huh
I'm like yeah he's like where are you
from and I looked up where he was from
so I said that Sandusky Ohio
it's like really I'm like no he's like
good cuz you were blowing my mind
was weird stuff right there but even he
brought me into the tell you what man
look at that guy meets like that
spider-man meme right there man that
came from us man more of a dick like me
I don't know maybe I'm not a dick good
thing on hard nights dude if you know
people that played for
grudem before its he cusses a lot oh
yeah a ton but on hard nights they edit
it all out no they left execute a ton
not like years man
yeah yeah the first time I went in there
when it was last year when they played
him when when they played the Cardinals
and came through Phoenix I said does
John swear at all they're like not
really and I hear me just starts yelling
I'm like he does Square a little bit
like every few words I loved him as a
commentator I thought he was amazed
always and he's fit he's so good he's a
winner he can do whatever he wants
I texted him before he got the job cuz
Adam Schefter the NFL insider had talked
about it on Twitter saying that looks
like Gruden might be entertaining the
thought of going to back to the Raiders
the silver and black might have your on
Gruden ash their coach once again I
texted Gerdes like tell you what man I
love that team I'm like is he telling me
this is before it was like months before
it's announced like I think he's kind of
tell him he's like sorry to turn that
down man also 10 million dollars a year
month some good cash man do you how many
beaver blankets you could buy with right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]